précision rigueur et travail ce sont les
ingrédients nécessaires à la confection
d'un burger de compétition
[Musique]
fromage aux oignons caramélisés
mayonnaise herbacée ou encore bacon au
piment d'Espelette ce burger permettra
peut-être à Anthony podra d'être sacré
champion de France le cuisinier de 27
ans s'est classé parmi les 25 meilleurs
sur 350 à la prestelection en ligne du
concours sur le thème du rock n' roll
tout autour je vais enflammer la scène
au moment de l'envoi donc le burger sort
en haut les flammes en sucre et ici il y
aura un rideau de feu qui va qui va
carrément enflammer le présentoir il
faut pas tomber dans le cliché américain
il faut pas tomber dans des dans des
choses qui se sont déjà vues donc
ça a été compliqué j'ai fait énormément
d'essais énormément de remise en
question sur les associations que je
pouvais apporter tout le monde sait
faire des bons burgers mais des burgers
pour être champion de France c'est plus
du tout la même compétition c'est plus
du tout la même la même vision du burger
et vraiment j'ai poussé la recette et le
burger au
plus haut point possible participé
pendant 10 ans et passer par plusieurs
grandes maisons anthony est arrivé au
restaurant lobe to you à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux en 2022 il
participera avec son burger à la finale
régionale puis nationale à Paris les
candidats ont 25 minutes pour en
confectionner 4 une épreuve qui lui
demande beaucoup d'entraînement je me
chronomètre dans tout ce que je fais
tout est chronométré je prendrai
vraiment la compétition comme comme un
sportif aux Jeux Olympiques qui doit
grappiller des centièmes de seconde des
centièmes des centièmes pour que le jour
J y est le une marge d'erreur qui soit
la plus fine possible pour avoir ce
résultat là j'ai passé bon nombre bon
nombre d'essais bon nombre de remise en
question bon nombre de recettes que j'ai
retravaillés que j'ai perfectionné
jusqu'à tant que le résultat ne soit pas
correct j'ai recommencé jour et nuit
donc ça a été ça a été intense j'ai
envie de rendre fier tout le monde j'ai
envie de trahir personne que ça soit mon
coach qui me suit mes amis mes proches
ma famille mes collègues je peux pas
décevoir je peux plus décevoir qui que
ce soit maintenant je dois aller au bout
de la compétition ramenez la coupe à pas
fini le Bretonneux pour être offrir
Anthony une belle reconnaissance
professionnelle après plusieurs années
au fourneau réponse le 12 avril